hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to freddy fazbear's
pizzeria simulator let's get back into
it i still have no
idea how to play what this game wants
from me
or what i'm supposed to be doing in any
of this but i've got money
and i've got the ability to do something
here
i don't know what it should be but hey
uh i'm gonna save my money just for now
because
i've got ned bear i've got i've got ned
bear here
that bad is do good me good and i've got
several advertisements up
i guess i'm gonna upgrade to a larger
floor plan now i'm gonna waste
i'm still gonna wait i'm still gonna
wait i'm gonna just go into this and try
not to die immediately because that was
my problem is because i i went straight
for the the the the
the thing i went straight for the all of
that and i didn't do the
the things i needed to do okay so what i
got to do is i got to order what i need
to order
i heard that already
oh god damn it i heard it already
what the hell so i need to be more
mindful of what i'm doing i guess
i don't know i heard him at least i
heard him
that's the nice thing i guess i gotta
shut off everything
okay
heard that
oh what was that all about huh
okay
i don't like it i don't like any of that
what is that noise
why
that's the fun fun noise
okay i think i'm fine oh wait wait
i heard something i think i heard
something
wonk hello
hello okay
back online get that there
oh i heard that
oh god i hate this i hate everything
about this i hate everything about this
i hate everything about this i hate
everything about this i hate everything
about this
i hate everything about this i hate
everything about you marty plunger
hey okay we're gonna try to do that
i guess order these goddamn utensils if
i could just get utensils for my goddamn
pizzeria i'd be so happy
they have to eat it with their hands
they have to shove it in
burning cheese all over their bodies
it's horrible in here
oh frick that's so loud oh god it's so
loud
i can't hear [ __ ] oh i can't hear [ __ ]
okay got that
okay everything's fine everything's fine
everything's fine wonk
what was that what was that
no no no no no no
no no okay
oh it's so hot in here oh 101. ah [ __ ]
i better die i'm gonna die that's what
i'm gonna do
i'm gonna just frick fracking die any
motion
no motion scanning
all right that's okay that's not so bad
come on okay motion
audio put that over there okay all right
maintenance
unclogged toilets get the toilet clogged
nobody had too many exotic butters over
in there
but if we gotta get those toilets
unclogged we're never gonna get our hair
alive
well that's bad
i am not causing a ruckus i'll have you
know
do not like that okay all right i think
we're good
i think we're good clean the ovens i
don't know why why can't the ovens clean
themselves at least they're not loud
gotta turn on the air
i'm thinking that maybe oh what was that
i think in the maybe i'm thinking that
maybe
maybe the quiet vents would be good
to have to have because if the quiet
vents are there
then there there's no not less there's
less chance that i get low
oxygen levels of heatness come on come
on come on come on this last one this is
the last one get it i'm outta here
i'm on it baby
okay i'm outtie i'm out here closing
time indeed
okay let's see if i can not totally mess
up this whole ordeal with the salvage
thing
before you is an animatronic found in
the back alley
we are unsure of its origins it is your
job to complete the maintenance
checklist before claiming it
as salvaged if you choose to
you can throw it back into the alley
where you found it and forfeit payment
please make your choice now uh i'm gonna
proceed i guess i've chosen to proceed
with the maintenance checklist
remember use your company as you taser
to return the animatronic to a neutral
state if you feel that it's becoming
unstable
or aggressive you can only use it three
times before it begins to
damage the animatronic and decrease its
value
begin audio prompt in three two
[Music]
one
you springy boy document results
uh no i begin audio prompt
in three two one
what are you saying to me
[Music]
i thought you said something to me
that's right yeah you don't give me no
attitude
springy boy i'm gonna document that as a
begin audio prompt in 3 two
one
[Laughter]
not really what i would call safe if
these audio prompts do something do you
document results
okay okay ah no you go back
you go back missy you going back you go
back
all right we got one more of those
two
[Laughter]
three two one no
[Music]
carry on what were you saying
this is a long one document results
okey-dokey
no you have completed the maintenance
checklist you may proceed with the
salvage
all right well done all right all right
hey that's probably safe deceptive
calling i knew it was a lie the moment i
heard it
obviously but it is intriguing
nonetheless
what why why would you want to run
that by me one more time you want to run
that by me here one more time
great job a lot of money
no lawsuits oh boy i'm so happy about
our legal system
i've never been so excited about
everything okay gumball swivel hands
oh behind me on stage lines oh yes
all right how about how about i get a a
deluxo stage i get rid of that [ __ ] ball
stage
that had the horrible things in it and i
marked down
purchasing a bulky item in this
condition comes with a significant risk
of something undesirable
but it's so cheap look at that how can
you even
i can't pass that up there's no way
there's no way i could pass that up i'm
not gonna get mr hippo come here
smiles and servos inc
yes yes yes i love it a ball pit
yes yes oh yes
all of it i want it all please give that
to me
i'll take that thank you very much okay
all right
yeah you're going up there mister
so happy in here i'm so happy that
there's happiness happening
you are
here i have candy all day every day
candy candy candy
okay i'm ready
space
[Music]
[Laughter]
and maybe i will candy cadet to you a
story
candy i don't like it
[Music]
i don't like you it's so big
i'm gonna look into this bad boy oh
you're so cute
[Music]
what wow hundred dollars
that didn't make any sense let's do that
again
all right
what are you dead return to candy cadet
again
and maybe i will tell you a story
[Music]
okay that's maxed out on candy cadet
candy cadet ain't going no higher so
wow performance bonuses why why did i
get those
why you know what i'm gonna upgrade my
floor okay you know what
i'm gonna can i move that where'd my
ball pit go there's my ball pit
i'm gonna go in the ball pit here we go
[Music]
all right well let's look at the
sponsorship ah flow's glossy floss the
true step to true romance flow's glossy
floss inc is offering to pay you for
advertising
yes give me the flow glossy flaws
give me play tokens left oh i can't play
anymore i guess
i guess that was it you know what we're
gonna put i'm gonna put some safety
straps on you mr candy
just cause i don't like the way you are
i want number one
crate i love number one crate i love
pans oh what do we got here riding rock
is lemonade
i don't like lemonade clown no fruit
punch clown mark down oh even better
than lemonade clown
oh who needs lemonade clown when you got
free punch clown i'm gonna buy the pair
rockstar freddy rockstar body
hell yeah rockstar chica hell yeah let's
rock
rockstar foxy rocky foxy roxy foxy four
four heavies i like that
[Music]
we got new balloons i can't afford any
of you
don't like that security puppet
is five dollars you guys seen this [ __ ]
lefty's five dollars oh my god
oh oh oh fun time chica
oh why is it unavailable where's my jar
of pickles unavailable
it's fifteen dollars very good condition
happiness one that happiness even it
isn't even a qualification on any of
these other ones
give me my goddamn pickles all right
whatever i'm gonna buy lefty
come here you all right fruit punch
clown
not fruit punch clown oh no i can't i
can't
play test em i've got no tokens
well that's a shame ah lefty okay put
you on the right lefty
lefty ain't too happy about that maybe
this was a mistake maybe this was a
horrible
horrible mistake
maybe he left he was a terrible error
maybe having lefty there was the worst
thing i could have ever done
i think it might be true guys i don't
know what i don't know what it is but
lefty
someone tells me he's gonna be ornery
about not being on the right on the left
on the left right oh well that's what it
is get ready for lawsuits
baby oh boy here we go oh boy
wait what about the uh the koopman ah
printer
spare handy hire handyman that's great i
want to do that
oh boy where's the motion ah okay
no please
thank you over there how about over here
oh something tells me i'm doing this
horribly wrong okay here we go
i heard that
[Music]
that still took a while two two two
two two of them two oh we got two
we got
how can i resist
uh what did you say i don't know what
kind of enigma you talking about but can
you
shut up and go away
[Music]
oh okay i see you two gonna get the last
thing on the printing
with my new spanking printer okay
they're over there okay that's good
that's a good thing
right that's good clean the ovens that's
good also that's done
okay so you can you can look around
while it's doing it
and i don't need that fan on all the
time
oh that's not good oh god oh god oh god
i think we're gonna be fine
all right
okay i shouldn't have gotten so many
advertisements
things shouldn't have done that
shouldn't have done that shouldn't it
no not there not there not there not
there no not there not there not there
oh i hate this i hit this i hate this i
hate everything about this i hate this
in every way oh god oh god oh god i'm
gonna die
i'm gonna die i'm gonna die i'm gonna
die
i'm gonna die i'm dying is what i'm
gonna do
i just gotta be a little smarter about
the uh air vent
because if i'm not smarter about the air
van i will die if i
if i don't need it then i shouldn't you
use it
probably i don't know how i don't know
how this works to be perfectly honest
i don't know anything about it replace
bulbs that's all i gotta do left
i just got to replace the bulbs i'm
outtie i'm howdy i'm outta 5000 i'm out
come on come on
i'm out i'm out i'm out baby
okay i'm outtie hey okay i did it
ooh this guy go through this one
salvation before you is an animatronic
found
in the back alley no way we are unsure
of its origins
right okay it is your job to complete
the maintenance checklist before
claiming it as salvage
or if you choose to you can throw it
back into the alley where you found it
and forfeit payment
please make your choice now of course
i'm going to salvage it
you have chosen to proceed with the
mainland's checklist what if you didn't
do any of this
use your company issued taser to return
the animatronics
to a neutral state if you feel that it's
becoming unstable or aggressive
you can only use it three times before
it begins to damage the animatronics
and decrease its value i know begin
audio prompt in three
two what if you didn't what if you
didn't accept any of these
what if you took the smart road and just
tossed them all back in the alley where
they belong because
i sure should don't want them here
document results okay
no audio prompt in three
one
[Music]
also what the hell is with the audio
prompts and why do i hate them so much
because i do document results okay
[Music]
begin audio prompt you three two
one
that's right you returned to a neutral
state all right it's getting ornery
see there's no point in this this test
is nothing it says there's nothing
because it's obviously hostile i have a
taser
and i'm shocking you of course it will
be hostile in audio process
would be two one of course
why would i keep it the test is
obviously doing
nothing
[Music]
you stop it you stop looking at me with
that i
don't like it prompt in three two
one
yep okay yeah let's go with those sounds
sounds of the dams
damden the damn dams those damn dams
okay great
wonderful hello wow this is a long one
huh
[Music]
document results okay nothing you have
completed the main
stop you don't look at me like that i
had an extra one
this checklist and may proceed with the
salvage
yeah definitely salvage
the salvage which is totally worth it i
don't really know who your employer is
do you i'm self-employed princess
i i employ myself
turned away are so many turned away new
lawsuits i bet there's going to be a lot
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah i'm pretty sure that oh what what
what where the hell is
she witnessed the head of an animatronic
fall off and roll across the ground
young girl was left impossibly and
grossly traumatized due to the
negligence of defendant fazbear
entertainment
when asked if she was okay she screamed
staff asked the head not to ask any more
any more questions the drama put the
young girl in a coma for
10 weeks she woke from her coma
effectively and lobotomized
she relies on her parents and health
aides for all functions in her life
except for watching tv hanging out with
her girlfriends and going to the mall
but
for the superbly reckless and careless
actions
she would not have suffered an egregious
and life-altering injury
[Music]
i'm a fighter i'm a fighter pending
all right oh god parents union against
unsafe atrocities and mechanical
abominations
a young boy was hospitalized for 10
months due to defended fazbear
entertainment's negligent preparation
handling of food stuff
he had contracted multiple parasites
from consumption of food and beverages
prepared at fazbear entertainment
parasite caused him to suffer explosive
century
including painful acute summer cramps
and terrible nausea such horrible
circumstances could not have been
avoided at fazbear's
simply follow the previous standards of
care for handling of footsteps but for
fazbear entertainment's cruel
indifference to human safety and health
he would not have suffered such
unnecessary harmony
there's no way you can prove he got food
poisoning yet
my establishment oh boy a young girl was
utterly and horrifically disfigured by
the reckless endangerment exhibited by
defendant fazbear entertainment while
patronizing fazbear
zoholi owned and operated establishment
her index finger was broken due to
established failure to install necessary
and improved safety apparatuses
the child has suffered immense pain and
suffering for inability to ever play
itsy bitsy spider again
but for the callous indifference
fastball entertainments are shown to
safety standards so digit will be all
intact
no way the itsy bitsy spider crawled up
another
goddamn tree so screw you oh it's
hilarious
oh it's so cheap though
deluxe ball pit yes
yes perfect i love it
excellent should i love it probably not
but oh well here we are
hmm carnival hoops yes that'll be good
ah rockets can't afford it okay
blueprint mode
i think i think one of this might have
something to do with old lefty here but
uh
none can tell the tale to be truth be
mattered ah
like it was never there wacky wart paste
oh wacky
oh let's upgrade this back oh yeah oh
that's the good stuff
oh look at this oh look at the balloons
yes yes i should probably take lefty
down but no
it's about the risk that's what it's all
about yes
yes put some safety straps on there
perfect
play test it ah what is this
why
oh no that's a bad thing
i'm supposed to avoid that no
yahoo frick i don't mean to be
that bad i don't i don't mean it
i don't mean it i don't mean it little
bear i don't mean it little bear
ah performance bonus performance
my performance is incredible anyway
that's all the time i have for this
episode thank you everybody so much for
watching there's a lot of cool stuff to
like see here and terribly scary stuff
too
so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you think down
in the comments below
and as always i will see you in the next
video
[Music]
bye-bye
you